it's about Nicholas winon an
extraordinary story about a young man
who visited Prague what he found there
with thousands of refugees he was
mortified knowing that they would all go
to concentration camps so he decided
heroically without aan fair to rescue as
many as he could he managed to save over
600 children he kept a scrapbook
meticulously kept all the names of the
children and he didn't want any
publicity nobody knew about it and he
was exposed publicly by as rans this
young man decided that something had to
be done that YouTube clip lives out
there millions of people have watched it
anybody who watches it um gets
overwhelmed we make it feel like it
would for him we travel into the studio
on Nikki's shoulder 30 seconds to on
air someone had this brilliant idea we
should fill the audience with Children
of the people that Nikki saved so when
you get to that moment that Esther
Ranson says anybody owes their life to
Nikki Winton please stand up they do
because they do owe their lives to that
way and here we are you survive there's
not a dry eye on the set Flor all just
sobbing can I ask is there anyone in the
audience tonight who owes their life to
Nicholas Winton if so could you stand up
[Music]
please